[Music]
Oh
we turns with all-new episodes Thursdays
a small box see youtubers is Charlie
they're already promoting season four
sauce a new round of the flash ring
giveaway starts now but there's so much
Batman stuff happening today so like
they say it's coming to Thursday nights
but they're going to premiere in
September so they actually have like the
least off time of any of the shows they
did that really weird thing where they
took this giant break after a couple
episodes earlier this year then just
dumped everything continuously including
a two-hour back-to-back finale so let's
talk predictions biggest one jerome is
coming back he was such a fan favorite
and the actor was on a different show
for a little while on Showtime
but then they killed him off so he
became available again so they did that
big jerome returns arc that was Bruce's
I will not kill moment he even has a
funny line from Bullock where he told
Gordon do you wish you'd killed him he
said I'd probably just come back to life
like the Joker always comes back somehow
penguin will finish his iceberg lounge I
don't think it's going to be nearly as
big as it looks in the comics it might
not even be on the docks it'll be
somewhere in Gotham the Riddler will get
sawed out they'll renew their war and
there's even something really cool
getting ready in the comics right now
called the war of jokes and riddles they
tease it at the end of the latest issue
which i will do a video for later today
Batman number 24 there's a big big
Catwoman moment it's this huge Batman
arc but the war of jokes and riddles
sounds like something that Gotham could
actually do really easily because it's
all about the Joker fighting the Riddler
over who has the right to defeat Batman
they don't want the other villain to get
the Batman before they have the
opportunity to beat him it's just a
really crazy idea that takes place less
than a year into Batman's costumed
career so because Gotham has put them in
this version of the costume you can
actually do some of those Batman Year
Zero stories pretty easily the minor
chains they'd have to make would be the
Riddler would be fighting the penguin
but got them because of the TV show is
so big and has so many characters
there's a lot of side plots that are
going on that have absolutely nothing to
do with Batman so the Riddler's war with
the penguin has absolutely nothing to do
with Bruce right now but hopefully
they'll find a way to include him
Batman's a nighttime adventures haven't
quite escalated to putting them up
against super villains like that so
they'll have to find some sort of
plot for the penguin to try and pull off
that will rope in Bruce that has
something to do with ratio cool they try
to tie all the plots together by the end
of the season this season was all about
the touch virus so there's going to be
some MacGuffin next season they will
help bind everything together
speaking of B R toxin they were talking
about scarecrow coming back and then
Solomon Grundy is obviously going to
rise but because he's a partial
elemental he's imbued with the similar
type of energy as Swamp Thing he's
effectively immortal indestructible the
TV show is probably going to change how
he comes back to life because in the
comics he just crawled out of a swamp
after being dead for four years does the
same way that Swamp Thing crawled out of
a swamp mysteriously there's not that
many swamps in Gotham he could crawl out
of the sewers but it's probably going to
be a combination of science and
technology that brings them back Hugo
Strange brought a bunch of people back
from the dead this season so on the flip
side of that more Hugo Strange
experiments running rampant the
executioner will be back
so we'll get Michael Chiklis back being
super crazy they said only 90 percent of
the city was healed of the virus so that
means that he might be one of those
people that's still running around they
spent all that time giving him that
origin story with that costume but cab
woman is still going to be a loner with
Tabitha they'll still be on the fringe
they have that Bart they might start
using it or that might be what the
penguin uses is his iceberg lash you
might just take that over but most of
her time is probably going to be spent
butting heads with the Penguins crew
even though she's still friends with
poison ivy
Bruce kind of gave her the brush-off but
they continued to put them together in
really funny ways and tease that
chemistry out so I cannot wait for the
moment where they bump into each other
where they're both in their costumes and
she immediately realizes that it's Bruce
under the mask but really the big thing
is Rachel Ghul coming back like they
tease he's the new big villain so his
ultimate goal is obviously to get Bruce
to become the heir just like in the
comics but it sounds like he's replacing
the Tetch virus in the court of Alice is
sort of like the big overarching threat
like you see his shadow cast over the
entire city so you have all these
regular criminal dealings that penguin
is going on on the surface level but
above that you have Rachel Ghul pulling
strings trying to continue to push Bruce
in the direction that the leader of the
court of Alice was they wanted to
cleanse the city
the court of owls had a very specific
vision only the chosen will survive
racial Ghul is all about wiping the
board clean he only cares about one
person in that city so let me know what
are all your Gotham season 4 predictions
which new criminals do you want to see
them bring on they've already done a lot
of his classic rogues gallery but we
haven't seen scarecrow in a while
we haven't seen Jerome so hopefully
he'll come back in a much bigger way the
only people I'm not expecting to see are
Talia and Nyssa but they could always do
their own versions of that but they'd
have to be about the same age as Bruce
so leave all your requests for DC TV in
the comments below there'll be some new
legends of tomorrow season 3 Black Adam
Shazam stuff later today but my next
video will be that Batman 24 the
Catwoman story so I'll post that in a
couple hours
while you wait for that click here to
learn all about Flash Titans crossover
and you can click here for brand new
Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight